okay wir kommen zum Finale das wir haben
uns wieder harmlose nette gemeine Fragen
ausgesacht die Grünen sind
harmlos du möchtest mal mit der harmlos
anfangen oder hast jetzt blind reingen
ist leer nee was bist du ein
Womanizer ja bist du ein Womanizer muss
ja nicht ich beantworten das MSS ja dann
andere beantworten für mich nee ich
glaube nicht Zeiten sind vorbei aber
warst du
mal zwischen 13 und 16 war da mal Phase
das war da ganz da lief es ganz gut und
dann nicht meh interessant spielst du
nicht zu wenige Hauptrollen nö nee
nö nö gibt so ein nicht so ein night
unter Kollegen manchmal es gibt ja dann
der KST der einees Hauptrolle der andere
die und die Nebenrolle ist das immer
klar ich spiele ich bin jed also jeder
Schauspieler glaube ich der Lust auf
Arbeiten s sagt dass er samanisch
unterbeschäftigt ist ob ich zu wenig
Hauptrollen spiele ja vielleicht könnten
mir Hauptrollen sein ich ehrlich gesagt
es klingt glaub wieder keine Sau aber
ehrlich gesagt mache ich diese
Unterscheidung nicht unbedingt also wenn
ich bei Ulf Spiele wenn ich den Ulf
Spiele ma ich mir jetzt keine großen
Sorgen ob das jetzt eine Nebenrolle ist
oder eine Hauptrolle also es ist halt
der Cast oder wenn ich irgendwie jetzt
keine Ahnung jetzt an Oster sononntag
Oster Quatsch grüonnerstag kommt ein
super schöner Film wo ich mit Robert
atzhorn ermittel auf SLT auf dem
ZDF ja gut da habe ich jetzt ein dr
Tagen geh als er ist Nebenrolle oder was
also ma ich ab dann spiele ich natürlich
zu viel zu wenige Hauptrollen fühlst du
dich mit deiner Patchwork family nicht
manchmal überfordert nee überhaupt nicht
ganz und gar nicht
weil ich so eine tolle patchwk family
hab klingt ja auch doof ich habe eine
tolle
Familie und da sind die Menschen drum um
mich so wertvoll und
so
toll alles andere mich überfordern würde
aber sicherlich nicht das ganz im
Gegenteil das entspannt mich total
komisch eigentlich dass es eine gemeine
Frage ist ja weil weil in dem Buch ebeno
diese Melancholie die du ja selber
beschrieben hast rüberkt und das also
mich hat halt ein bisschen mit
Traurigkeit erfüllt und ich denke immer
ist schade also ja es ist schade absolut
ist schade ja es ist schade dass es
soweit kommt aber da muss man das Beste
draus machen ja klar absolut und dann
muss man
ich ich finde es halt toll dass ich so
emotionale intelligente Menschen um mich
herum habe und äh das finde ich einfach
großartig das ist toll aber das wünsche
ich auch jedem das erfordert natürlich
Arbeit ist klasse das ist der Idealfall
oft ist das ja auch gar nicht fühlst du
dich manchmal unwohl in deiner Haut ne
letzt mal hast du mich schon was was
gefragt habe ich irgendwie was gesagt
irgendwie dann fand mich alle eitel und
so unwohl in meiner Haut nö also auch
nicht manchmal es gibt nicht Momente wo
du sagst ich wäre gern das wä
sollte ich nein
nicht genau W nein ich fühle mich wohl
in meiner Haut fühle mich wohl ja ja gut
wir werden alle älter man kriegt ein
bisschen Rücken und so ein bisschen
hatmer so ein bisschen Gicht oder keine
Ahnung man kriegt ein bisschen muss mehr
Wasser trinken oder so aber
nee alles gut gut macht dich so
sympathisch keine
Ahnung aber nicht viel Mühe gegeben
dieses Mal doch was macht so das ist
eine Standard es ist eine gute
Standardfrage ach so weil die es ist ja
kannst nicht be fiese Frage ja ja
natürlich sind die auch ja weil
eigentlich wenn ich jetzt antworten
würde mich macht sympathisch erstens
zweit
sagen nein ich muss mir mal so Standard
fr Standardantworten auf solche Fragen
ausdenken oder schreiben lassen am
besten wenn du gefragt wirst warum bist
du sympathisch dann antworte das gibt ja
nur bei uns solche blöden Fragen was ist
dein
Erfolgsgeheimnis ich bin sehr
diszipliniert ja das heißt wenn du an
Set kommst kann es Dir nicht passieren
dass du den Text vergisst
oder ich bin zu ja nee ich ja das kann
schon mal passieren aber ich glaube ich
bin trotzdem sehr diszipliniert also ich
bin wenn ich wenn ich was durchziehen
will und wenn ich was machen will dann
setze ich mich da dran und dann ja ich
glaube so ein Buch oder so schreibt man
vor allem mit Disziplin absolut ja also
das ist glaube ich glaube dass ganz ganz
viele Menschen draußen sind und die
ersten 30 Seiten ihres Romans in der
Schublade haben und nur die Disziplin
ist es die sie hat nicht du grinst so du
we nicht zu Ende Schrei nein weil wir
haben ja auch dieses Buch Youtube Buch
da habe ich erstmal 30 Seiten
geschrieben ja und danach war es was
Arbeit ja weil du halt weißt wie es dann
aussehen wird du weißt in etwa wie es
dann am Schluss aussieht und so und dann
hast du schon hast du ein paar Leuten
gezeigt die sagen alle hey super dann
hast du schon den ersten Flow an
Komplimenten denkst du so komm jetzt ma
auch irgendwie Mittag oder so fühlst du
dich manchmal verkannt
ähm manchmal ja ganz ehrlich ja das
heißt du hast ein anderes Selbstbild von
dir als manche die Außen dich beurteilen
privat weniger ja weil da habe ich ja
immer die Möglichkeiten mich dann auch
so zu äußern und mich so zu geben wie
ich bin beruflich fühle ich mich
manchmal verkannt ist jetzt aber glaube
ich auch kein nichts Unnormales glaube
das Fühlen viele wenn Sie eine Rolle
nicht kriegen Rolle nicht kriegen oder
ich glaube auch z.B dass dieses Buch
viele Menschen überraschen wird weil sie
nicht damit rechnen oder das ist das was
ich von Journalisten zurzeit gerade
zurückbekomme als Feedback dass man
einfach nicht damit rechnet dass man mit
so einer Tiefe nicht rechnet oder dass
man wenn man mich halt nur aus einem
Genre oder aus einer Rolle oder aus
einem Rollenfach oder so kennt
dass man damit nicht rechnen da fühle
ich mich manchmal verkannt ich Fall ja
deswegen aber in keinerlei in eine
Depression mhm mir geht's gut dabei ich
kann ja was dagegen tun okay gut vielen
Dank ich danke
dir